the key things about Detroit's
bankruptcy or that it didn't happen
overnight and it didn't have to happen
at all
Detroit's light really started in 1950
when the Motor City's population peaked
at nearly two million people now it's
only around 700,000 the hollowing out of
the city is on gut-wrenching display in
two recent exhibits at the National
Building Museum
featuring photography by Andrew Moore
and camellia Vergara in fat times in
lean the city's polls and power brokers
chose to focus their energy and their
residents tax dollars on gigantic big
ticket scams while ignoring the basics
that let cities thrive or at least
survive Detroit's leaders poured money
into a never-ending assembly line of
sad-sack projects such as the
Renaissance Center the Fox Theater
Comerica Park whole town the People
Mover
and Ford Field unlike Pompeii and other
cities crushed by nature's wrath or
God's wrath
Detroit's destruction is completely
man-made and thus can be reversed the
city that Midwife the Model T in the
Cadillac Bob Seger and Eminem Ted Nugent
in the insane clown posse still has
tremendous assets in terms of
infrastructure and location of people
like Buffalo Cleveland st. Louis and
other dead cities scattered across the
map of the industrial Midwest like so
many cigarette burns Detroit Ken staged
its own comeback by reducing crime and
picking up garbage by frame kids parents
and property values from an abysmal
school system and getting the government
out of everything that isn't absolutely
essential in other words Detroit's
leaders only need to do what they should
have been doing for the past 60 years
and the city's dwindling number of
residents need to keep them honest this
time because Detroit is finally out of
next eyes for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you